you can't necessarily make a wrong
decision it's a matter of what you want
to do with you your career and obviously
i consider my family right
what do they want to do where they want
to live where they're comfortable with
and
then obviously the team
[Music]
riley it's so good to
there's so much to discuss you know the
last time i saw you uh we were at our
dear friend jason's golf tournament and
jace and i were unfortunately losing to
you and your wife kamaya and spades
ah see yeah that's that's what we do
like my wife knows we get very
competitive with spades so yeah
if if one of us messes up during the
game we hold that in the back of our
hearing car ride home we let each other
know so yeah have you ever beaten jason
in spain lost to jason and states uh
you know what
no
they may that may be our first time
actually playing so really you you took
this for sale like right along with them
unfortunately it was it was sick because
i take spades very seriously so i was
sad that we lost uh then they went to
play blu-ray and i was like nah i'm not
rich enough for this boomerang game
get ugly there absolutely so booray in
the nba is like this underground thing
that everyone plays but a lot of people
don't know how to play
how much money have you lost playing
blu-ray
oh
i might have to tell you after
it's that much
no i've never lost that much yeah
uh
um
i don't know if i add them up it may be
a little bit but i've won
a lot too so i'm like i don't know
i'll tell you after okay how have you
taken a lot of money from others
yes unfortunately but you know we're all
it's all the brotherhood so you know
it's better than us going to a casino or
something like that we all yeah
we keep it in a family yeah it's really
like this thing it's how y'all like kill
time on the plane and i feel like it's
this bonding experience that happens
playing blu-ray it is and it's we're all
competitive players as that's just our
nature and then when it comes to cards
it's even more you know of a competitive
spirit outside of basketball so
and it's another way for us to build
some some some camaraderie some some
good brotherhood outside outside of the
court too so
uh gambling is is intense we don't
recommend it for everybody yeah like me
you know what you're doing or you don't
because
i've been a part of a lot of vets in a
lot of games where
there's no teaching involved and you'll
get your head cracked really quick yeah
i was like this is a very very serious
game um but obviously you and jason are
two players who don't really need any
more bonding you guys are already like
brothers it's very well documented this
really strong relationship that you two
have but you know i like a nice moment
on the show i love when people get their
flowers so jason has a message for you
that i am going to play for you
okay i'll give you my phone
it's very sweet
okay here you go
straight from jason
what's up uh
just wanted to stop by
um
you know i guess for a surprise video
taylor asked me but
uh
you know just want to stop by and you
know i've said it a million times i'm
gonna say it a million more times before
it's all over with that uh
you know i just want to say
i appreciate brad
everybody know how close we are you know
that's the
my big brother that i never had
uh you know appreciate all the the talks
um the lessons and things like that you
know i you know
for me as a person as a player you know
i wouldn't be where i am today without
you
um you know just that
true role model right that you know i i
saw you know growing up and that you
know pushed me to be better and to be a
better person and player
and that's something that i always
admired and appreciated that you know
you always wanted me to be better than
you
uh
you know and that that meant more than
everything so
uh you know the real saint louis
goat legend you know cause without you
it wouldn't be me
so um you don't get enough credit but
i'm always giving you the credit
um
and you know you gotta relax man you got
chill
you know you you i be able to tell you
all these videos you cussing out the
kids
you gotta chill but uh
no my big brother man appreciate you you
know it's all love you know i'm gonna
see you
just something
don't let us do it no
what's it like hearing him just talk
about the impact that you have had on
him and his life and career
it's uh it's surreal in a lot of ways um
that's dope uh yeah you're like getting
emotional yeah a little bit
uh cause
for me i didn't have that
that image per se like to me my older
brother was my favorite player outside
of you know the goats and the legos we
see on the court in the nba
so i didn't have that image of what a
pro is like you know
what recruiting was like you know going
through that phase like i seen it within
my family and so that was my way of
learning
you know on the fly and so it's funny
that he talks about my aau team because
he was a part of that it was way before
i called him brambill elite years later
um but i used to yell at him and chew
him out the same exact way
um
but that speaks volumes you know that
just speaks volumes of his character
and uh and just who he is like for me
it's the same with jason same with all
the kids i coach every kid that's
ironically we're playing against some of
the kids i've coached in
in the league now you know my au team so
it's the same message to all of them
like
i did it you know and i didn't have
a spoon in my mouth i didn't have the
picture perfect blueprint of what to do
how to do it but you know i knew my hard
work would get me there
you know if i just trusted myself and
believed in myself and obviously
listened to
my parents and the right figures around
me you know i can take advantage of the
opportunities that i had so
um for jason now
look at him now he's in the finals right
that's something that we always we talk
about we never
you never imagined that happening you
know your biggest thing is making it to
the nba but then
to be here to be star player max player
nba all-star superstar all nba guy now
you're in the finals like
you're almost checking every box so now
you got what two more games left to get
so yeah
i commend him i salute that because
he he is
he's becoming the face of the league
totally yeah i love it i mean his words
like clearly meant a lot to you so i
thought that's really good you were able
to hear that you know i think we
sometimes underestimate what it means to
have somebody deeply believe in you
and you have known jason since he was in
diapers you were babysitting him your
moms are friends
and you always if you like told him that
what he's doing right now
is what he could do like you always saw
that in him so when he's going to the
finals what's that phone call like
i don't call him i don't bother him i
don't bother listen i don't bother him
because
it's it's funny because people
always ask like do you still give him
advice and it's like it's subtly like
because he's he's going to develop into
his own player and his own man and
you know what got me here may have
worked for him but now he's he's here
like now you create your own path you
create your own you know your own legacy
now and and he's doing that you know
obviously i'll throw in my little
my big bro hints here and there but he's
got it like you know he's i think the
biggest lesson is his experience you
know and somebody can tell you all they
want through their experience and what
they went through you can prepare for
that but once you're in that fight and
in a moment it's totally different so
yeah
i let him rock and i'm always here to
pick him up if he needs me yeah
now you know i hear you were taking 16
year old jason to the club st louis
so that's what i hear
uh and i know his mom found out oh yeah
yeah and you got cussed out by miss
brandy
i want to know how she found out
saint louis is small saint louis is no
bigger than his roommate like so
everybody knows each other so it wasn't
probably wasn't too hard for her to get
back around to her but
she was furious like she's
miss brandy she's never yelled at me
before
that was the first time she's ever cut
like she cussed me out i was like okay
yeah
never again i'm i'm never getting on
your backs i ever get hey
don't ask we're not doing it i'm not
doing it
strictly hoops my brothers
okay he's he's grown up now so you can
tell us whose idea was it to go to club
was he like brad take me to the club i
want to go
it was a little bit of both it was
probably him more so than me but i'll
take i'll take the blame because i was i
was older i should i knew better so yeah
you're like accountability i'll take the
accountability for it okay fair one
thing you always say about jason you're
like he is going to be the future face
of the league so i want you to fill in
the blank for me here okay
when it's all said and done
we will talk about jason tatum the way
we talk about
oh
you put me on the spot
so he's still writing the story
um
i don't know what to say i want to say
all the greats but there's so many like
like i think he can be a top 10 player
when he's done
like top ten player all time
right
yeah if he puts his mind to it yeah and
we can be talking about him like a top
ten player for sure and his like ascent
has been absolutely crazy so love that
for jason you know
he makes fun of me because i'm not
really from saint louis but i was born
in saint louis but i think it's great
but we're still we're still we got you
like i'm repped a little bit it's like
you know i'm from georgia but i'm in st
louis all the time so it's really great
what you guys have just done for st
louis basketball uh funny thing he says
in that video though is about you
cussing at the kids you had a bit of a
viral moment talking to your aau team
which i loved why do you think it
resonated with so many people online
i think because sometimes we we kind of
sugarcoat a lot of things with our kids
like i'm a father now and so
seeing how my mom raised me like that's
that's a little bit of my mom coming out
like that's how she coached me that's
how she coached me and my four brothers
so imagine
how our household was and how strict it
was and how you had to push like
in the black community we don't have
everything given to us right we have to
work almost two three times as hard to
get that advantage
and for me the au circuit for us is our
opportunity is our advantage and i think
a lot of times
are us as kids and i was in it as well
like we lose sight of that like we lose
sight of you know how many games you
have right and how many times a coach
can see you throughout the summer right
granted all the rules have changed since
i've came up but
like
taking for granted how many games you
have the opportunity to play against
your best peers on a circuit like every
kid on every au team is their best kid
in their state yeah every single one but
once you get on a national circuit it
becomes totally different like playing
an nba
right so
you magnify that and it's like
go like go like this is what you wanted
like don't shy away from it embrace it
even if you fail like fail but know what
to do
on the back end of that and how you can
come out on the other side of it and so
that's just
my vision for it like continue to just
push and
i feel like if they have
an nba guy
league and there's plenty other who
plenty other guys are doing anyway bl as
well like if they see our faces hear our
voices see our impact like
they do it immediately yeah it is
sometimes it's frustrating because our
coaches
will tell them tell them tell them tell
them what to do and then the moment i
come in and say the exact same thing i
said
they go out there and do it right okay
but
so it's just trying to get them to
understand like it shouldn't take for me
to do that it shouldn't take for me to
cut you out it shouldn't take for this
crazy
me being angry you know kind of in a way
at you guys for you guys to kind of
grasp like go like this is your this is
your life this is your dream this is
your your career like you got to take it
by the horns and run with it yeah
because i thought the video was great
because obviously you were somebody they
they respect that they have seen do it
and you kept it really real with them
and based on what you're saying it seems
like they respond to it very positively
but there are some people that felt like
oh my gosh you're not going to like that
it's not how they want to be coached but
how have you seen them respond to that
style
it is hit or miss and like i've seen her
i see the reviews too in like this last
video like i purposefully didn't post it
because i myself wasn't all the way
comfortable with what i said like and
looking back at the videos like okay
yeah i might have i might have said some
stuff i probably could not have said but
the thing that i love is that my kids
understand what i'm saying within my
message like they're not listening to my
curse words they're listening to my
meaning of my message right and so
if it's so funny because after that
there's another video of the guys
laughing smiling because we went three
and one the rest of the weekend right
and after and so just to be able to see
them retaliate in a positive way like
that's all i wanted and there was no
more yelling there was no more screaming
like you do what you're supposed to do
you know you guys hold yourself to that
standard and accountability and it'll
naturally just gravitate like winning
just creates this joy and this passion
and i'm sure enough they grasped it and
understood that and they had they had a
hell of a weekend absolutely so the
viral moment was incredibly productive
it helped them
push forward i'm sure though it has to
be in the best ways right this passion
for the kids want them to do well but
you want them to do so well that also
becomes frustrating yes so like i tell
my coaches college coaches coach donovan
when i talk to him in
wes when i talk to him like
i get why you guys get frustrated with
us like i understand as coaches why you
guys get frustrated with us as players
because
we get hard-hitted you know
so i get it especially younger players
like our iq isn't all the way there yet
and so
your patience has to be at an all-time
high as a coach yeah so i'm
understanding that i'm grasping that and
it's kind of a teaching lesson for me
too in terms of leadership and how i can
kind of move forward too yeah
so it's kind of changed your perception
of other coaches that have had to coach
you for sure like i'm i'm not always i'm
not gonna bark at coaches as much as
i probably have before or
um because
yeah i get it i get it especially in the
nba too you got a lot of egos and chrome
being here too so it's a difference when
in your life would you say you were
least coachable
i don't think there was ever a point
where i was i was ever not coachable
okay good because my mom made sure i was
coachable
and
yeah she yeah
she got you together
it's interesting though because
obviously aau has changed so much from
when you were there to now
in what ways has social media uh changed
the younger players um
it's become this mentality that if
i don't see it you didn't do it
and it's kind of that's kind of
frustrating because
i used to have a lot of kids right after
a game we'd lose and oh it's
what dunk is posted today or
you know what highlight is posted today
how many points did that happen it's
like
it's not what's important your college
coach dang sure don't care about that
you know and nba we damn sure i don't
care about that either so
it's just
like you understand the importance that
like social media has and
having a platform and being able to
have recognition from even like a
smaller city kid like that boost that
boosts you in a lot of ways
but it can also be kind of hinderous in
a lot of ways too to the kids because
they become okay that's
let me do it let me be flashy let me do
that just for for viewers or from this
like
that's not what the game's about yeah i
mean and it can happen so heavily that
it genuinely impacts the way they play
basketball which is detrimental like
everybody just wants the highlights and
i think that in some ways we're kind of
seeing the effects of that some good
some bad but it certainly has it has
changed the way how do you think that we
get out of that will that change or is
that kind of here to stay
i think that's the thing that's here to
stay it's kind of tough like it's tough
to avoid social media yeah as much as we
want to like
say let's not do that like it's it's
there it's in front of us like you don't
want to look at it our brain thinks
about it you see it so it's like it's
already there and so
it's kind of up to the kid to you know
just like in yourself realize what's
important realize you know
you got to stay disciplined you know in
your career and what you want to do
and reaching your levels and goals uh
because one distraction which social
media can be
it'll drift you of course
do we see like in the future maybe
bradley beal nba coach
oh no
i'm trying to like that's that's that's
part of the reason why
like i go back and do a lot of things
with my au program every summer like my
summer is scheduled around my au team
that's great
like they come first i'm getting i'm
like dedicating my time to that because
trying to feel like if that's something
i want to do when i'm done like because
it is so easy to
be caught in the game and it's just it's
just moving so fast like i'm going to
year 11. like i don't want to count down
the years but it's like
i got to think of something else to do
once this ball starts to bounce
i'm kind of trying to get a grasp of if
i enjoy coaching and i like it to an
extent i don't know what level i would
coach i don't know if i can coach the
nba because it was it's a lot it's a lot
yeah
and
but
for the most part my mom was a coach so
it kind of in the blood i kind of have
it naturally yeah one thing you said in
the video that just resonates with me
the most is you said y'all are focusing
on the wrong [ __ ]
how long did it take you to start
focusing on the right [ __ ]
um
it's tough because i wasn't
like my growing up my support system
didn't allow me to
get like drift off course and me
personally i like i didn't
i put boundaries around myself to where
i didn't allow that to happen but yeah
it's tough like i was like is the way
like it's me my four brothers
mom and dad like we were all
in one household like my best friends
were my brothers that's i grew up
playing against my older brothers
getting that experience
beating up on my little younger twins
so i wasn't really allowed
to get distracted to drift off course
or really to not really take it
seriously like it was something that
i remember my mom and i agreed when i
was a sophomore i mean a freshman she
said whatever you get offered with first
basketball football that's what we're
going with
and all four of my other brothers are
football players
right so i love football that football
is probably my favorite sport yeah but
kansas offered me as a freshman and
she's like oh that's it basketball and
so it just became okay let's do it let's
do it let's do it let's do it so
i kind of always had it within me to
just stay on course and it is tough to
do it's not easy like because
it's a lot of sacrifices you have to
make as a kid like you don't
you don't get to hang out with your
friends you don't get the party you
don't get to go to the movies all the
time you don't get to do live the
regular life as a kid my mom that's one
thing i always remember my mom said like
you're not a regular kid she always said
i'm like yeah i want to be a kid she's
like you're not a regular kid
i used to get frustrated but
here i am
28 29 years later i'm like okay i'll get
it in full circle so
it's it's it's about how bad you want it
if you want it you won't be a regular
kid yeah okay man i want to rewind a
little bit how good were you at football
that was really good
really yeah like what's really good and
what position were you i was a receiver
okay receiver is my favorite position
receiver and safety and i would play
quarterback if
i needed to let's do it at all
i wouldn't say do it all but i was i was
an athlete
were you like okay this is the thing
i want
it is really it's tough for me to watch
football because i love football like
all four of my brothers play
and so
it's like in us to
have that spirit and just want to play
football but
ironically enough i'm the skinny skinny
guy of the group all my brothers are
lying tight in so they're all
big husk boys and yeah my mom said okay
string bean you gotta you gotta stick
with basketball
that's what i do because you know the
guys that feel like you know i'm good at
this but i would even been better at
football are you do you feel like that
oh because it's tough because i've never
wanted disrespecting nfl players or guys
that do it professionally at their level
but i was really good i was i'm 6'5
on a great day
and the receiver so they i think they
can they can understand like i'd have
been like a dk
megatron randy
just bullying out there wish we're
thinking huh
yeah hey there guys he would have been
megatron no i'm just kidding
oh that's so funny well we will always
imagine i'll imagine would have been
like rally field nfl player
okay so obviously you know as i'm doing
the research for this interview
a lot of articles coming up about
reports
i want to know
what it's like to be on the receiving
end of reports because obviously for us
you know we get our alerts we check the
apps and all those things and we see
your name when we see that it's being
brought up and all these things but for
you when you wake up near a subject of a
report just like walk me through what
that feels like how that day goes
what it is for you
for the most part it's like wow i didn't
know
that
if there was something to say like that
i said that or that's what i was
thinking or that's how i felt
um or
more or less like that
that's an atmosphere or that that's a
possibility like we
like i said before like we have social
media so we can't avoid totally those
things and when they come to us so
i mean i take it as a great level of
respect you know from
the sign that you know a lot of teams
want you and
it's a good thing um as well as a team
that i'm on so
it's uh
it's it's fun like i don't shy away from
it like i kind of i kind of embrace it
you know because
i could be a player that is trying to
fight to stand you know but i am
somebody who's
wanted so it's like i'm doing something
right but you know i gotta obviously be
better and do more
uh but it's not it's a good feeling it
is a good feeling
so i have to ask
would it make you feel
better
if
more of the reports were about
a star coming to join you here
as opposed to
you going somewhere else
all the time for sure
uh
that would be night and day make you
feel better yeah um which
it's been tough for us to get get some
get some of those going home
we're gonna need some of y'all to just
rally up some of these reports for me
no but it is
no for sure like that's
like you don't you can't believe
everything you see but
some things do have legs you know and
uh to see
something like that that would be that
would be
that'll be unique for us yeah
and i would think in a time like this
where obviously you have big decisions
coming up
you're talking to management a lot
what have those conversations been like
what is your main talking point they're
always straightforward and it's just
always about the improvement of the team
yeah that's that's the biggest
and
our main concern like
the commitment's there from everybody
and
it's just a matter of okay how can we
get better what steps do we need to take
to get better how can we help wes who's
was his first year you know so he's
obviously getting his feet wet how can
we help
ease his way into it and help him be
better
um and then we uh have to play better
and be better be a better leader and how
can we improve our team you know
obviously we came way short of where we
wanted to be last year so
you can't necessarily come into the
season with the same mindset same kind
of outlook you know you gotta you gotta
be different so
our our conversation is always
straightforward that's what that's one
thing i love and appreciate about the
waiters good yeah okay so speaking of
decisions i just want everyone to be
clear on the numbers
so you can sign yeah we're getting into
it
you could sign a five-year 242 million
dollar deal if you stay with the wizards
you go somewhere else four-year 179-mil
obviously big numbers but a difference
and that means you are in a very rare
position of being able to control what
you do where you go
does any anxiety come with that because
you are the person deciding what the
rest of your career is going to look
like
uh
yes and no because there's so many ways
in which your deal can be
right
whether you stay or go there's just a
million different ways in which your
deal can look like so in that way you
can
you can get a little impatient when i
settle down like kind of narrow down to
what you want to do
but
um
i always had one of my my og's drew good
he always told me like i would he's like
my mentor and he would say brad
these are good problems
right and there's like great problems
those are great problems like it's like
when i look at it like that it's like i
can't
you can't necessarily make a wrong
decision it's a matter of what you want
to do with you your career and obviously
i i consider my family right and
what do they want to do where they want
to live what are they comfortable with
and uh and obviously the team for me so
it is
it is surreal in a lot of ways to be in
a position i mean you know it is crazy
numbers it is
it is what it is like it's
uncontrollable like it's out of my
control um but
um i'm blessed to be here you know so
again like i don't shy away from that
like i totally take it on
with the forefront and uh and i have to
do what's best for me so there's some
little anxiety because i have to make
the decision yeah time is is counting
down we're in general now but um it's
fun it is fun to be in a position yeah
and they are great problems you know and
it's good obviously the wizards believe
in you and one year but there's other
teams that also want you and
so i am in no way trying to simplify the
situation i know that there is a lot of
nuance that goes into it but one of the
reasons your situation is unique is
it would feel like at least to the
outside world that's why i'm asking you
that this feels like a decision of
am i gonna pick winning
or am i going to pick um money and again
i am not trying to simplify it but i'm
just saying what it feels like it is
tough like
it is so it is a blessing and a curse in
so many ways because
like
financially like yes it is
it is a lot of money and
i guarantee you if you take a poll of on
twitter okay if you got offered this
compared to this
everybody in their right mind would sign
the big boys it's still 63 million more
yeah
i get that and
that is tough but like i can't concern
myself what other people would say and
think like that's going to be their
opinion like i know
what
what my decision will be based off of
and that's going to be where i feel like
i can win
right and that's going to be my decision
if i feel like i can win in dc that's
what i'm going to do
and i want people to respect that you
may you may not but i'm going to fight
my ass off i'm going to compete and i'm
going to try to make this team better if
it's elsewhere it's going to be the
exact same commitment so yeah
it is it's twofold like you're gonna
have people rooting for you saying go
you're gonna have people saying stay
you're gonna have people say
take glass you're gonna have people
saying all type of stuff so it's like
all those things are options yeah
everything's an option but for the most
part
i'm gonna do what's best for me and i
can't concern myself with
what other people would say even though
it
may look as simplified as people may
project yeah but nothing is as simple as
it seems
okay in one word tell me what do you
want for your career right now
ooh impact
okay
why impact
uh
because everybody's legacy
is
it's kind of everyone obviously
different for me it's like what impact
can i leave on a team organization a
teammate right
was i probably one of the best teammates
you've ever played with right was i a
good leader for you
everybody has a desire to win i want to
win but i also understand how
crazily of a window you have to have to
win right to some of the most talented
teams in the league
who aren't playing right now right you
have two super teams right now that are
competing their tails off so
winning is hard and you know obviously
like you want to put yourself in a
position to where you're competing for a
championship 100
but
uh understanding how tough it is to win
like that that puts a lot of things into
perspective like in
terms of your future and what you want
to do and where you want to go and who
you want to play with yeah um but again
something there's they're good problems
and yeah
just kind of face them here and gotta do
well yeah so impact is one word for what
you want and one word tell me what you
don't want for your career right now
[Music]
that's a good one
i think the biggest thing would be
i guess i kind of i kind of just said it
a minute ago like if i didn't give
myself a chance to win
right if i didn't give myself a chance
to win i think that would be
i feel like that sounds like the word is
almost like you don't want regret like
you don't want to not
give yourself that chance strong but
somewhat yeah yeah in some ways uh
but you because you can't necessarily
have regret you have to live with your
decision true right
good or bad because you make whatever
however the outcome is that's that
develops your character develops who you
are that's what i believe in so
i don't i won't say regret but
you don't want to look 20 years down
loud like dang i wish
but
that's kind of having that regret in the
back of your head so
um
in a fine line of that i would say yeah
that would be
kind of what i wouldn't want to happen
yeah okay when i was watching uh the
interview that you did with draymond i
want shout out to drama um
you are talking about
like you say there's a lot of teams that
are saying okay we can get it done here
and you're like well
why can't we do it here
right like it's like we can do that and
you believe in the organization and your
ability and bringing people here and
building that up
which kind of begs the question of okay
well why hasn't it happened yet right
how would you explain why you feel like
it hasn't happened yet
oh
this is obviously like we might be here
all day if we explain that
i've been here what 10 going on 11 years
like we've had windows like plenty of
windows when we just we missed it right
and
we've made it to the second round we
made it to game seven the second rounds
before like we've
we've given ourselves chances to kind of
be that team
i would say the last few years we just
we didn't produce it's simple like we
we fell short obviously we had rush two
years the year before and
that was that was pretty good the cover
year uh it was tough with a playing game
we made the playing game
8c going in played
play philly but it's
it is tough
to get free agents here for whatever
reason and that's that's kind of always
been an achilles heel here um
like we've kind of more or less have to
draft and rely on the draft
and developing our gods
um
and
it's tough like we've moved on from a
lot of guys we drafted from a lot of
guys that we had who
probably killing on other teams and now
you're looking at like how much since we
started yeah
uh i mean it happens it's the league
it's the business um
but you know it's
it's missing our window like you gotta
like i said before it's so tough to win
a league and once you have the
opportunity that's you got to take
advantage of it you know sometimes i
think it was a few times we didn't we
necessarily capitalize on them um but
we just got to keep developing for
whatever reason we gotta figure out a
way to get guys here i think when a lot
of fans watch basketball they they kind
of forget that
you all do go home and you have like
these feelings and emotions
and one thing you and jeremiah talk
about on the podcast is
how sometimes it feels like the money
doesn't matter if you're losing and the
word that you all use is because you're
miserable
how have maybe these past years
professionally impacted you personally
it hasn't been packed
okay i'll be honest like if my wife is
here she'll be a little bit more honest
because sometimes that comes home and
that's what i try not to do but
like
losing can do that right and
yeah we make a lot of money and we care
about our money obviously we want to
secure and make sure our financial
future is secure but
you don't like getting your ass kicked
every night you get tired of it you know
and so
you obviously you're not a quitter but
at the same time you
you don't want to keep chasing your tail
yeah um
so it's a fine line it is a fine line um
but
there are it has i won't say it changed
me but it's
it's kind of opened my mind and
perspective to
the game in a lot of ways you know and
being happy truly happy and what it what
that looks like and
and kind of
where that is and i think that's the
toughest part and you can't just like i
can't just up and say oh i want to go
there i just don't just work like that
and so
uh
you know you look at everything in full
scale and kind of see
what's best for you but in years past it
has there have been moments where it's
bothering me for sure yeah
what moment sticks out
oh no
oh it was a few years ago it wasn't last
year was a ruffinger it was we were all
over the place like this was crazy like
the last few years i don't make excuses
but we had a lot of crazy stuff going on
yeah within our team we're covered in
these last two years
but
i was hey what was it two three years
ago i think it was
i think we lost to chicago and it kind
of eliminated us from being in the
playoffs
one year i think was the year before we
got rushed
that
that loss really bothered me i would say
that was probably one of the biggest
losses i was like yeah this bothers me
because i want to make the playoffs bad
like i wanted to make it bad
i wanted to i wanted to get there and
that loss for whatever reason that was
like ah this that one stuck with me for
a long time like i was really frustrated
with that one really
but why do you think it was that one
specifically i don't know it was tough
because we had
i think only like a few games left in
here like we really needed this game
and we didn't get it it was like
man we didn't get it so
and i think it was a game i had 50. so i
think that was even more reasonable
yeah because it's different talking
about that 50 when it comes with the w
but it wasn't even that it was just the
fact we needed to win to get in the
playoffs and i was like yeah damn i'm
trying to do everything we can to get
there
you know what i wonder honestly i'm
happy to say that because when i watch
some guys in the playoffs that obviously
are getting things like 50 points having
great games
and the team still loses
is there like a feeling of like
helplessness like you're like i'm doing
everything i can
and it's not working in this moment or
what feeling comes with that when so
much is on you and it ends up not being
enough yes and no okay
like from the point of being like
exhausted you're like damn like
i don't know what else i could have done
but
the competitive side of you was like
damn maybe i i could have did a little
bit more maybe there's something i
couldn't do better
um
i think that's a lot of players are like
that more or less they like put it on
their shoulders and
could have made the game easier for my
teammates and could have done like you
just feel like whatever reason you just
put it on your shoulders and
the helplessness like sometimes you feel
like they get dramatic but
uh you don't feel great about it like
i definitely i hate losing when i have
big games like that like it's yeah
it's like you might just wash it away
doesn't matter
whatever just put the l on it
it's frustrating
so you talk about that chicago loss
being like kind of a low point for you
because you weren't able to make the
playoffs
what is it like for you watching the
playoffs
oh it's tough it is tough because
obviously they're your peers and you
compete on them you compete against them
throughout the year
and to see the joy they have and how
how much the game is
it rises even much more like
it's like dang i gotta be out there like
that's kind of your feeling and so
it's definitely motivation and it is
like inspirational like even that's what
i'm saying like watching jason like
that's inspirational yeah seeing you
playing the finals like that is
it's a dream come true right but
it's also motivation but damn like i
gotta
pick it up like i need to be here like i
need to get that experience and so
uh for sure it is definitely tough to
watch but it's fun to watch because it
is it's nothing like playoff basketball
like i've had
plenty of chances to play in the
playoffs played in big games but
to see it every single year i feel like
the competition gets better and better
and harder and harder like it is
i enjoy it yeah
yeah absolutely so this is my thing now
i'm just like giving like my prognosis
you are so talented like you are
one of the guys in the nba like you can
do it all you're a leader you're a good
teammate
and sometimes it's just like
you feel like you want everyone to see
that and it feels like they don't all
get to see it
do you understand what i'm saying
do you ever feel that way
some sometimes
yeah sometimes it's like look like look
it's right there it's right there
yeah but winning
winning solves it yeah that's what i
just keep telling myself like
you can sit here and beat your beat your
chest all you want
hey hey
like draw the fireworks whatever but you
gotta win yeah you win you get the
attention you win you get the the
recognition the accolades all that so
if you don't win you don't get that
stuff that's that's one thing that i've
learned throughout my career like
winning is super important winning is
the cure to everything yeah do you feel
like
you get your due do you feel like you
are appreciated
as a player
yeah yes
yes
amongst
the organization and my peers for sure
like
i definitely have
their respect and
like i know every single time i step on
the floor okay yeah that game plan so
it's like
to have that
like that's another respect factor
that's like
you never dream of that you know you
wish you just get in the league but to
develop into
like an elite player
and
the game plan for it's like okay yeah
like that is you're one of them so
i embrace it and it is so it is super
fun but it's not easy i would say that
[Music]
yeah that's not easy okay that's fair so
one thing that uh we always do as a top
five
your top five in no order okay
i want you to give me the top five
current players
that we don't talk about enough um
i was going to say zach but we start
talking about zach over the morning
you can throw him in there if you want
to down
okay zach levine
chris middleton
good one
i feel like book was like that but i
think we know we're booking yeah he's
arrived
who's gonna get there dude
let me tell you some guys i thought
about and you tell me yeah
i thought about dejante murray
yeah i feel like people don't really
talk about even though like he was in
all-star it's like people don't really
talk about him as much as they should
i thought about drew holliday i know we
already have a book on there but drew
but i think one i think people got
uh they still don't talk about drew a
lot but he
he's a guy
and i mean i'm a hogs fan but to me
clint capela
i don't think people talk about him
yeah um those are those two i said i
know you said you said zach levine chris
middleton are we putting dijon tan there
i'll put
part of me wants to say shea but that's
a good one
yeah
jay yeah only one more
oh
who's a big
it's always like small market teams that
have really talented you know what i
mean
i think desmond bane now
for sure
i'll throw him in there okay desperate
that's a that's a solid five
years too
yeah he's still young huh yeah second
year
or ricky
i don't think he's a rick i think it's
his second year yeah yeah so used to
this one but you know what's crazy
though as you talk about desmond bain
and so many of them
we underestimate just how big of a save
those playoffs are
because when you make it there and you
go crazy like now everyone knows desmond
no one probably was checking for desmond
even when the grizzlies were hot it's
just that stage is it's um how you
making money it really is show up in the
playoffs that's how you make your money
yeah but no that's a that's a very solid
he was big for them throughout the year
yeah got hurt
uh
dylan got hurt like they like he was
there yeah
so and he's gotten a lot better so
i salute him for sure
for sure
so obviously like i said everybody talks
about how you are a great teammate great
guy to be around um i know john wall is
like your brother you've talked about
you all's relationship
he was in the news uh this week because
colin coward said he doesn't make his
teammates better uh did john wall make
you better yes
yes how so
oh he helped me iq was he helped me
understand
the floor
spacing of the floor i've never played
with a better passer than john
to this day
john was super elite at that
so for me
like
understanding the pace of the nba game
um
like he was he was my mentor coming into
the week so
for me to say he didn't help me would be
blasphemous like
he'd come up here slap me next time
that's i would never say that like
john's helped me in so many ways um
paul hanlon
learned how to read a pick and roll how
to pass out on pick-and-roll um
understanding where guys will be on the
floor like he was really great at that
and so
that learning that from him like when he
got hurt and i had to
play point guard who helped me johnson
you know so i'm not
yeah yeah no and i like i love john i
think he's so great he's so funny um and
it feels like there was somewhat of like
an evolution to you all's relationship
would you say that's accurate
how would you describe that evolution
where'd you start was the middle
what was the end
because it played out a bit publicly
that was
probably a lot of incorrect stuff but
from the start i would say we were young
pups trying to find our way in the week
and trying to both be alpha dogs
and
allowing social media and media to kind
of alter that with us
the middle part is us being adults and
actually talking and having a
conversation like yo is that how you
feel no is that how you feel no okay
we're good so yeah that eliminated all
of the noise
um and i think now
our relationship's even tighter from
um
i hope you don't mind me talking about
this but when his mother passed right
and so
i dropped everything was i'm there for
you right so
that for him was a different type of
bond and relationship and
a brotherhood for me so
to this day like if he needs me i'm
dropping everything go to him like he's
a brother you know yeah for forever and
so
him his family has two
amazing little boys he has like
they say everything for sure so
our bond is unbreakable like and i think
that's that's kind of where it's it's
transitioned to
so that's my brother forever
and that's really a testament to youtube
because
i think that a lot of times it doesn't
go that way any teammates who want to be
alpha dogs they'll see these reports
things about maybe someone says about
them but they don't have a conversation
and that conversation i'm sure was like
the difference maker for you too so how
do you approach that and how much did
that conversation help
it helped a lot because
we were somewhat stubborn like
like we're like dang is that how you
feel like because you're just reading
like you can't avoid it you see it and
that's and then when you're like okay
you know we have to talk we gotta have
this conversation like we can't just be
playing basketball yeah and
playing great games but not saying
anything we're not addressing the
elephant in the room so it just it
literally got to the point where i
already let's go to lunch let's go to
dinner do you remember when you had it
it was actually i think it was in
memphis
it was in memphis we had a little
barbecue yeah nothing like a barbecue so
memphis thank you yeah
yeah good barbecue good conversation
it was over it was over a meal
and you were good it was good it was
like just the complete opposite of what
you were reading so yeah
see look at that guys this narrative
they hated each other it's awful right
out the window
[Music]
okay like it's over friends we got it
okay good uh another person obviously
you by the way when i was looking at
this you have done so much in your
career like there has just been so many
things that have happened uh people that
you have played with um but russell
westbrook's another one uh i know that
is someone you are also um incredibly
close to
as well what do people have wrong about
russell westbrook because i always tell
you he's the nicest human being oh for
sure the nicest is the greatest guy yeah
i was just with him in
a.u basketball in louisville yeah russ
is in louisville
like russ can be nothing against
louisville but
russ could be anywhere in the world
spending time with his fam but he's just
like me he's with his au team he's
investing his time mm-hmm and
he's he's unbelievable he's a great man
great
individual great husband great father
and unbelievable teammate like
when he's on your team you love him but
you hate playing against oh yeah right
um
the i don't know what it is about
what they have wrong about russ or why
he gets as much disrespect as he does
like i guess they want him to
shoot a million threes a game and make a
million threes
but
russ is
going in what year 14
15 maybe
like he's
he's in he is who he is you can't change
who he is like he's played this way his
whole career has played hard he goes
hard that's why
i'll never disrespect him like i
witnessed it for 82 games
and so like that pushed me
to a new level like i had my best year
of my career with russ and so
i
i hate the disrespect he receives but
yeah
i do commend him for
for sticking in it and and
just
just being a man about it and obviously
competing still but yeah it's not easy
to do like i think
the dynamic of their team was tough for
everybody to play totally i think just
the way they were assembled as a in
total was tough for all of them to
really
excel at what
they could do i think a lot of them were
out of position and
it was tough
can you explain to others the way
that situation impacts
your career
a
a
lot
nothing and that's that i think that's
what's so tough because you don't have
control of where you get drafted
right so
all of us will love like if you're a top
pick sorry you're not chances are you're
going to an elite team
are very slim right so
as a young kid you that is
tough and you have to that is a
different lane than somebody who's going
to
go to state or boston right now right so
your learning experiences and curves may
be totally different your playing time
may be totally different you're going to
get thrown right into a fire more that's
going to
you know as a top pick
but you know at the same time it's
that it's just that it's just the
business and the reality of the league
like you want to be
who you want to be gotta kind of put on
the big boy pants yeah
absolutely well you in a lot of ways
you're a mentor to so many guys you're
incredibly well liked in the league and
you make a huge impact in your community
i know you were doing that june 18th yes
yes with the the basketball court tell
me all about it so i partnered with who
for all as a non-profit in d.c
it's a group of howard alum students um
and literally we're refurbishing an old
court that's across the street from the
university and it's a court it's
literally two courts
citizens of dc used to play on all the
time and now it's like
not even a playing surface like it was
unbelievable just to see it but for me
it was like i want to find something to
do
in a city where i can leave like a
like an imprint like a lamb not like a
landmark but like a you know some type
of memory here right and so
they approached me about it and i seen
like they were a very small non-profit
but they like this is something that
they did like they did a lot of court
refurbishments and so i was like okay
this is this is exactly what i want to
do you know io the head guy and he is
unbelievable and uh in the entire team
and so i'm excited june 18th i'm in dc
will unveil the court it's being painted
on as we speak so amazing i'm excited
about it um the city will have two more
course to play on and
rick for the youth so i'm excited about
yeah and it's also great because it's
happening juneteenth weekend as well why
was that important and significant so
that's exactly why we chose that weekend
right so obviously we didn't want to
have it on it on juneteenth day we want
to pay the homage to that day but we're
obviously 100 speaking on it and
addressing
juneteenth and and celebrate it in in in
a little way uh
for sure so on that weekend the whole
weekend in dc is going to be crazy that
weekend so
uh i think we'll get it started on 18th
and 19th and so on would be crazy yeah
and you know the word that you used
about what you want in your career right
now was impact um does this kind of help
feed into what that impact is going to
be 100
you know because
we love the fans like them fans will ask
you what your legacy
what do you want your legacy to be but
like how did i impact you did you enjoy
watching me like when you interacted
with me was i
a great guy right or did you catch me on
a bad day which i try not to do
has them yeah
uh but yeah like what i can do in the
community
you know how i can uplift people
how i can utilize my resources utilize
my platform like that's one thing i told
hoop for all like i want to utilize my
platform to lift you guys up on what you
guys do like this should be
recognition for other people other
cities other
states other organizations to want to
partner with you and kind of create this
idea because
ironically over the last year with
especially since covert street ball has
been kind of a thing now like we're
starting to get back outside and play
basketball again on blacktop so
like for us to do that probably do this
project
it's like that could be like a little
thing we create so
totally however i can utilize my
platform and
again leaving an impact on people is
what i care about no i think it's
beautiful congratulations on that so
june 18th that's what uh he's doing
random do you still eat skittles before
every game no
i still
i i want to bad but i i don't i don't i
mean so
once a week never like are skittles
still in the diet i would say once a
month i try to cut down on my sugars i
know i'm getting old yeah i'm getting
old yeah in the video i saw you like i
do them before every game oh yeah i was
a sugar rush for sure yeah
was it like helping or it was just your
thing i was hoping for
sure i was ready to go
and i was like i gotta cut back
nowhere
and you ended up choosing uh the
barbecue chips over the skittles which i
was surprised by because you said you
ate the skittles all the time wow
i probably wouldn't do that today yeah
like you're picking skittles
okay so i have i have to ask you this
it's just your words i just want to
clarify so uh what and done this so you
said
in march march 3rd
when asked whether you're leaning on
staying with the wizards you said it's
fair to say
does that hold true is it still fair
yeah that's what we've been the same
that's been said nothing nothing is
nothing's altered me one way or another
like i'm always
like we talked about earlier everything
has been straightforward with the
organization and
that is a fair statement for sure until
i feel
otherwise i'm here yeah well good i hope
you make the best decision for yourself
you are great love your family shout out
kamiyah she's so fun cute kids and she's
pregnant
right
yeah oh my gosh when is she due soon
she's ready to pop now she's driving me
crazy
uh
no middle of july amazing another one
i assume was just like you're like okay
another one's gonna be coming around but
all the kids are so different i'm sure
you get so equally excited this is like
there's gonna be one more it's like yeah
but you gotta start all over again
a lot of work
it's a lot of work yeah no sleep but i'm
glad we have summer baby so i don't have
to deal with this in the middle of the
year yeah and you have like two boys
that like get in everything they're [ __ ]
they're like everywhere yeah i always
say my boys run the house i just live
there play the bills
they run on the show every single day
got the schedule going
uh you know i'm just the guy that visits
and walks around so
well that's beautiful next time i see
you you'll be a dad of three
yeah slow down
down july come slowly um any fan
questions are we good
uh a lot of finals predictions oh i mean
i feel like he's gonna go to boston i do
have a lot of green on today i mean
well no purpose i swear
um but i am
draymond gonna kill me
but jason would also kill you so either
way you got to just say what's in your
heart i'm going jason i really want
jason to win i want jason to win if that
makes sense y'all yeah jason i'm not
saying boston with jason you want jason
to do it i got you has there been
anything in the playoffs that surprised
you like the whole playoffs either a
performance a team not making it to the
finals like what has been the biggest
surprise
ah
i wouldn't say anything's a surprise i
would say
it's a lot of young guys up and coming
in the league and everybody's on notice
now i think that's
that's kind of the biggest
grasp that i got from the playoffs like
yeah a lot of the teams probably didn't
make it or didn't as far as they wanted
to but
those series were competitive yeah
probably wore down a lot of teams and
altered them in the next round so it was
i would say it's a lot of teams that are
you gotta okay you gotta lace them up
yeah you gotta be ready to go so
uh but to see
kind of see the run that boston went on
to go through
you know brooklyn milwaukee miami uh get
to a dallas that's a tough run that's a
tough run and that's the thing they took
down the giants yeah like yeah they went
through it they didn't
they kept saying they didn't duck any
smoke they didn't they did that through
the big dogs yeah okay last thing before
i let you go because you said this and
it's true there's always this
conversation about like the guys under
25 that are so good like that there's
just so many really good young guys in
the league and we talk about it a lot
but
why do you think so many of like the
best guys are so young
does that make sense yeah i don't know
yeah it's like why is it happening right
now i don't remember a time that it was
so like youth heavy yeah it is i don't
know i mean it's it's a different
age in the game it's like the game
always evolves that's one thing you
can't stop yeah stop the evolution of
the game and
young guys are just kind of like they
don't want to take a back seat no more i
just know i'm here yeah you got to
respect it because they put no they are
putting off yeah and what's really
striking about the young guys like
they're not scared like normally when
the younger guys get in you can tell
they're kind of like oh [ __ ] like i'm
playing lebron i'm playing whoever knows
these guys are like let's go yeah
there's no fear in them
yeah yeah and i feel like that kind of
lends to their performances too so it's
a really fun time in the league it is
amazing it's that's why i love it it's
super competitive like
i don't know how many teams would have
predicted the series i mean the finals
to be what it is you know with all the
amazing teams we have so
it's a testament to our league and and
the growth of it for sure yeah well
thank you so much for your time you're
fantastic i'll be an awesome show thank
you i'll be watching for the decision
and all the things i'm excited are you
gonna do like not one not two
yes but no you were great count down so
it's gonna be yeah it's coming up do you
know when you're gonna like
say what you're doing
can you tell us that you're like just
gonna
no i'll have a date my birthday is june
28th so i guess oh maybe
around now ooh maybe around the birthday
you heard it here no seriously thank you
so much for your time and your openness
and all the things
[Music]
you